we have big political news this morning
former vice president joe biden is now a
2020 presidential candidate
he released a three-minute campaign
video this morning calling out the 2017
white nationalist rally in
charlottesville virginia and president
trump's response
that there were very fine people on both
sides
a senior campaign says that for biden
what happened in charlottesville quote
shook him to the core and it is the
moment that he decided he had to run
i believe history will look back on four
years of this president
and all he embraces as an aberrant
moment in time
but if we give donald trump eight years
in the white house
he will forever and fundamentally alter
the character of this nation
who we are and i cannot stand by and
watch that happen
biden is now the 21st candidate for the
democratic nomination and polls show
that right now he is one of the
favorites to win it
ed o'keefe is covering the 2020 campaign
good to see you good to see you guys
he's using that phrase again that this
is the battle for the soul of this
nation what does that tell us about how
he's going to wage this campaign tells
us he's ready to throw some punches
uh and then is far more willing to do it
than other democrats in the race so far
so
we'll see now in that video this morning
biden talks about how he believes
americans
are in a battle of soul nation and in
the coming days we expect to hear biden
talk about restoring an inclusive middle
class
we've talked several times this year
about the diversity of the democratic
field more women
minorities there's an openly gay
candidate now
consider the age gap at 76 biden is the
second oldest candidate in the field
of democratic contenders behind the 77
year old bernie sanders
when biden ran for president in 1988
this cycle's youngest candidate
thirty-seven-year-old pete boudages of
southman indiana
was just in kindergarten it's unclear if
biden's more than 40 years of public
experience will translate
to voter support also unclear what kind
of financial support biden will earn his
first test is how much money he raises
today
the number to beat is 6.1 million
dollars raised by beto o'rourke on his
first day
on the campaign trail earlier this year
you might also be wondering about joe
biden's former boss president obama
and where he stands in all this in a
statement this morning he said picking
biden as
his running mate in 2008 was quote one
of the best decisions he ever made
but we're told he is unlikely to throw
his support behind a specific candidate
this early
in the campaign but it's interesting too
i mean he's really talking about that
the core values of this nation
are at stake i mean he comes with a
wealth of background
and to take him on and essentially what
are issues of character right
exactly he starts and he founds his
announcement uh
in charlottesville virginia in august of
2017
and is making a claim he's he talks
about america shouldn't be a place where
you give hate safe harbor yeah
which is an attack on the president i
mean all these other
candidates have focused on themselves
who they are what they would do it is
telling that somebody who has
universal name recognition is willing to
spend a little capital right here at the
start
he doesn't need to introduce himself to
voters they already know his bio should
we be surprised obama is holding back at
this point no because i mean i think
uh if the shoe were on the other foot
eight years ago or how everybody
can't do math this early in the morning
he wouldn't have wanted an
incumbent stepping on on the race and
would have understood that you know as
somebody who came from behind to win it
and probably in the view of many people
it should be a wide open race
we'll see all right ed thanks